okay true story uh the other day I walk
into our wonderful Offices here in
Larchmont Los Angeles and I stroll in
and I I hear that uh our talent
coordinator Maddie Ogden is chatting
away she's terrific by the way she is
she is great she has this amazing sense
of style uh she's very funny comic in
her owner she's a very funny uh stand up
comedian and she also greets all the
guests when they come in she makes them
feel right at home she puts these
baskets of food I encourage you if you
haven't been a guest on the show be a
guest just to meet Maddie and get the
snacks yeah okay you do not have to be
famous uh trust me that's the new
culture anyway
Maddie was talking and she apparently
had had some dental surgery and sort of
they excavate the tooth a little bit and
then uh if you clean it out too much you
get something called dry socket that's
where literally some of the nerves and
then this is going to freak some people
out but some of the nerves in the jaw
get exposed and it's temporary it goes
away
but what you have to do is you have to
put a little bit of a medication in
there that numbs the pain okay so you
have to literally drop this medication
down into this little hole in your tooth
and it numbs the pain and then you're
fine okay this brought back a memory a
repressed memory that I have okay okay
and it's a story about what an amazing
man Andy Richter is
that's here's how it goes
a number of years ago when I'm doing the
Late Night show back in the old days in
New York and Rockefeller Center I had to
have this work done in my tooth and they
said we're going to finish this up later
but you should be fine you're going to
have some pain
um so here's what you do
get someone on your staff
to here's a little vial of liquid and
aesthetic get some of your staff to take
these little balls of
um of cotton tiny and dip and soak them
in this liquid anesthetic and then reach
back with tweezers and here are the
tweezers we're giving them to you and
drop them into this part of your tooth
so I go thinking how big is the hole
it's like a little hole in your tooth
not that big in the tooth yeah so I'm
getting to it so I I think oh this will
be easy and so I I I get to work and I
think wait a minute who do I ask to do
this and I'm I'm I'm kind of looking
around I'm thinking you can't ask an
intern and I'm not going to ask my
assistant this is just weird I don't
know who to ask
what am I gonna do maybe I could yell at
a writer no these writers they all have
you know they're all addicts and stuff
their hands Shake that's not going to
work so you know I'm telling the problem
to somebody and I'm saying uh yeah it's
starting to hurt now and Andy Richter
God bless his soul my on-air sidekick
says I'll do it
what's the big deal so anyway for about
two weeks before the show he's dressed
up he's in makeup I'm dressed up I'm in
makeup the band's playing
I don't know why they did that song
um and I'm in my dressing room and Andy
would come and go like it's you know
4 30 time to go and he would take out
the stuff and he would like an expert he
would dip the little cotton ball in
there and then go open wide and I'd open
wide and um I don't know why he's
Roseanne yeah and then he'd reached way
back there and like with this seriously
with the skill of an eye surgeon he
would drop this little pellet into the
hole this was pretty small and it would
go down and land perfectly and go all
right let's go to the show oh my God you
know did Regis ever do this for Kathy
Lee did Ed McMahon ever do this for
Johnny Carson special this is special
that's nice and I just thought I it just
gave me this reminder that like I think
I I blocked all of that out you know
whether you're on a cross-country drive
or on your daily commute time in the car
is perfect for listening to podcasts
like I don't know this one
T-Mobile covers more highway miles with
5G than anyone their Network helps keep
you connected to all your favorite
podcasts when you're out and about I
gotta tell you I like to road trip
sometimes I do too and I have T-Mobile
and I ca I can honestly say there's
coverage that's important like there's
been times in my life where I'm out on
the road driving around and uh
especially on those family trips you're
out in the desert you want to make sure
you have that coverage yeah what if you
get like your car breaks down and you're
just there sitting there like a chump
yeah with no coverage yeah not this guy
I've got T-Mobile got 5G if you find out
more at t-mobile.com see why that's
s-e-e-w-h-y what'd you do for Andy
um I remember trying to push a five
dollar bill into his hand when it was
all over five yeah he could have gotten
him a nice gift I thought I said hey
buddy go out in the town tonight me and
it was a five dollar bill five in New
York City I know I didn't do anything I
don't know I was a child of the
depression so I thought he can he can no
I mean I was very depressed oh right but
I thought he could go out on the town
my mother used to do that she would send
us to the store there's like six kids
and she she'd give us you know a quarter
and say Well if you get sodas
until Franklin Roosevelt I said hi all
right but we used to go like Mom you
can't get we can't all get Cokes for a
quarter well I think you can
uh but anyway I was just I had this
sense because Maddie brought it up I
thought that's unusual that's that's the
kind of I was lucky lucky have a real
friend like that turn the favor to her
and put her little pellets in her mouth
no I think in today's climate that would
be creepy yeah yeah you did you did
officiate his wedding recently so that's
nice no and to be serious to be honest I
didn't press a five dollar bill into his
hand no no it was seven dollars oh
crinkly old up ones most of which
were taped together
but anyway I just had a this is a memory
of something that I remember very
clearly and and also what an unusual you
know we had a you know a TV show that
was on a network and it's kind of a big
deal and we have this big studio and big
guests and no one would ever believe
that if I told them that it's literally
minutes before we go out there and do
this show and Andy's saying ah
countenance have a seat you're right
Andy it's time open your mouth dip dip
dip dip squirt Scorch bombs away I'm
surprised you guys actually didn't do
this on the show I know we should have
done it on the show but uh no I think
it's okay
I will say this whenever that stuff used
to wear off oh man that would uh you'd
feel you'd you'd feel that I would feel
that so yeah get it but anyway
um Andy Richter a great man and an
incredible Dental technician oh he's
he's not well he's yeah I think he's
actually being schooled right now he
learned he said I was like oh this is
fantastic
he's one of the best in Beverly Hills
it's a side it's a side hustle for him
he makes millions of dollars a year and
that's all he does is drop little
anesthetics down tiny holes I wish I
hadn't said tiny homes